Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Stephen from Tacoma. Stephen,
welcome to the program. What's going on today?
Speaker 2: Yes, sir. Can you hear me? Yes.
Yes. I wanted to talk about the thing around RFK
Junior right now and how he's doing so well in the
polls right now. And how much of that do you
think is not really his policies, but mainly
his right name recognition as a Kennedy?
Speaker 1: I think that the domain name
recognition is a part of it, but also his. I've
seen some breakdowns and his support seems to have
spiked in particular actually, among Republicans,
interestingly enough. And the other thing is,
if you go back and look at look at his polling, I
have it on the screen in front of me in early May
and late April. Let me say it more chronologically
in late April, early May. There are a bunch of
polls that have RFK around 20%, like there's an
Emerson poll that had him at 21. A Fox poll that
had him at 19, a CNN poll at 20. Now, he rarely
even hits 15, like there's one poll that has
him at 17, but now he's as low as eight and
typically in the low to mid teens. Overall,
RFK actually seems to have lower polling support
today than he did several months ago. So I don't
know. I don't really make much of it one way
or the other. I think that it's potentially a
spoiler campaign. I think there's a lot of MAGA
people that like it because it's chaotic and it
might hurt Joe Biden. But, you know, I've talked
about it. I feel like I've struggled, Stephen,
to find the right amount to talk about RFK. When
I don't talk about him, people say I'm ignoring
him because I'm scared. When I do talk about
him, people write to me, say, David, this guy's
got no shot and he's cuckoo. Why are you even
talking about him? You know, if you're polling
14 in the Democratic primary, I think it makes
sense that I talk about you a little bit, but
I don't find the entire thing super impressive.
Speaker 2: Okay. Yeah, because I figured that a
lot of his name or a lot of his name recognition
was helping him in the polls and whatever weight
the Kennedy name still has. But I think for I
think for really anybody under maybe the age of
40, that's kind of a historical name. That's just
kind of my $0.02 on it. But I as I can see some
of the polls, he's starting to go down. People
are starting to notice that he's getting more
support from like Steve Bannon and all the MAGA
people. Yeah, and people are starting to figure
out they're looking beyond the Kennedy name and
realizing, oh, wait, this guy is he's he's a I'm
not going to say the term, but he's trying to mess
up the potential primary or potential Biden vote.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, we'll see
where it goes. But my money is that it doesn't
have a lot of oxygen left to grab.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I figured that,
too. All right. Oh, thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you very
much there, Stephen from Tacoma. Very,
very important subject matter being
discussed in general on today's
program. And I appreciate that.